[Musica]
Vi è mai capitato di reputare di aver
fallito Vi è mai capitato poi di
impegnarvi talmente tanto per
raggiungere quell'obiettivo
vi è capitato poi una volta raggiunto qu
quell'obiettivo chiedervi e
ora ecco è proprio da quel E ora che io
vorrei
partire una volta che raggiungete un
tanto atteso e ambito traguardo Come vi
sentite
vuoti persi
alla ricerca subito di qualcosa di nuovo
Beh giusto porsi nuovi obiettivi è
importante gli obiettivi sono importanti
sono il motore della vita ci consentono
di andare avanti e ci
motivano Però c'è un ma ci metto un ma
qua tutte quelle energie tutte quelle
conoscenze tutte quelle competenze
acquisite che fine
fanno potrà veramente tutto finire con
il nostro obiettivo potrà tutto finire
per che abbiamo raggiunto quel
traguardo è proprio su questo che io ho
riflettuto negli ultimi anni vi riporto
Quindi ora degli step della mia vita che
non reputo essere degli step salienti
cioè lo sono stati per me ma poi ognuno
ha i propri ed è lì che vorrei
arrivassimo
2 ottobre del
2015 Io già lo
sapevo me l'aspettavo ero andata nel
pallone durante il test speravo in
qualche tipo di miracolo bel miracolo
non c'è stato non ero entrata a medicina
avevo
fallito ricordo ancora le emozioni urli
pianti lacrime ricordo come ho sceso le
scale di casa mia piangendo ricordo
ancora gli occhi dei miei genitori
disperati
ricordo il modo in cui vedevo me stessa
e il mio futuro completamente nero
questa sensazione È durata troppo tempo
è durata giorni settimane mesi ma poi
per fortuna è arrivato un click È
arrivato quel click che mi ha fatto
ricordare che il mio sogno era diventare
medico e che nessuno poteva prenderselo
Mi sono detta che avrei fatto qualsiasi
cosa fosse il mio potere per raggiungere
quell'obiettivo
Mi sono detta che avrei fatto qualsiasi
tipo di test avrei comprato qualsiasi
libro avrei frequentato qualsiasi corso
pur di entrare a medicina e questo ho
fatto ho dato il massimo
e il 6 settembre del 2016 alle ore
13:30 ho scoperto di avere un posto a
medicina urli lacrime pianti Questa
volta però di
gioia è stata un'emozione pazzesca ma è
durata un attimo l'attimo dopo mi sono
già chiesta Ma è tutto
qui tutto quello che io ho fatto E ora
che fine fa dove va a finire avevo
imparato decisamente troppe
mnemotecniche avevo imparato decisamente
troppo Come gestire il tempo avevo
scoperto ogni segreto ogni metodo che
c'era dietro al test di
medicina avevo imparato addirittura a
gestire la mia emotività
e ora che ci facevo con tutto
ciò Ecco lo potevo usare per aiutare
perché io c'ero passata perché ora avevo
delle armi in mano ora avevo delle
potenzialità delle competenze delle
conoscenze per aiutare chi come me
temeva quel test per aiutare chi come me
sognava il camice bianco chi voleva fare
una professione
medico-sanitaria E così ho iniziato il
percorso di tutoraggio di preparazione a
chi appunto voleva fare medicina e in
questo modo il mio obiettivo non è
terminato con me ma è terminato con i
ringraziamenti gli occhi pieni di gioia
e i successi dei miei tutorati ma la
cosa più bella è stato vedere che quello
spirito quello che credevo io ero
riuscita a trasmetterlo anche a loro ed
Alcuni di loro si sono messi poi ad
aiutare chi voleva entrare a medicina
Ecco che quindi non solo il mio
obiettivo non è terminato con me ma
nemmeno il mio desiderio di
aiutare arrivo ora al secondo step
l'università qualcuno di voi sa cosa
vuol dire essere studente di
medicina
competizione valore attribuito sulla
base dell'appello in cui dà gli
esami valore attribuito sulla base la
tua media dei voti e poi c'è la cosa che
più non sopporto gli appunti
nascosti appunti nascosti perché sai io
C'ho impiegato tempo io c'ho investito
energie tu no E allora io valgo io
merito la lode e tu no e quegli appunti
che fine fanno una volta che tu hai
superato il tuo esame carta straccia io
non ci stavo la mia energia non può
terminare con me con il mio esame e con
il mio
obiettivo terzo step e poi giuro che è
l'ultimo
Erasmus
2020 non so se sapete cos'è l'erasmus
alcuni forse non lo conoscono è un
periodo di mobilità fatto all'estero che
può durare 6 mesi o un anno Insomma sono
andata fuori ho avuto la possibilità di
fare questa che è l'esperienza più bella
che l'Università possa
offrirci Erasmus vuol dire cultura
conoscenze amicizia amicizie lingue cibo
però vuol dire anche tanto altro vuol
dire difficoltà vuol dire difficoltà di
un paese estero difficoltà di un paese
in cui tu non conosci
niente Insomma avete sentito i miei
genitori erano
immigrati e così anch'io in questo modo
mi sono sentita straniera io ho capito
cosa vuol dire quanto avrei voluto ci
fosse qualcuno che mi capisse quanto
avrei voluto avere lì qualcuno che ci
fosse
passato per fortuna quel qualcuno c'era
c'è stato c'era passato e mi ha mi ha
saputo aiutare e capire Quindi dei
termini incomprensibili come transcript
of Records Learning agreement budy e mi
ha
orientato Quindi io c'ero passata ho
capito le difficoltà che vive una
persona straniera una persona che viene
e vive in un paese che non è il suo ora
che lo capivo avevo capito che potevo
far qualcosa Anzi volevo F qualcosa e
quindi quando sono tornata mi sono
ficcata in qualcosa di nuovo
un'associazione che si occupa proprio di
Erasmus ho concluso Quindi quelli che
sono gli step della mia vita che mi
hanno portato a credere fermamente in
ciò che vi ho appena esposto Però ripeto
ognuno ha i propri step per me gli step
sono stati il test di medicina
l'università l'erasmus ma per voi può
essere qualsiasi cosa reputo veramente
qualsiasi un percorso in palestra una
delusione amorosa qualsiasi evento della
vostra vita che vi ha fatto vivere
un'emozione forte che avete per cui
avete
lottato qualsiasi esperienza qualsiasi
traguardo qualsiasi difficoltà porta con
sé di conseguenza un potere immenso un
potere immenso che può essere utilizzato
per
aiutare Quindi ora voglio chiedervi di
fare una
cosa vorrei chiedervi una volta usciti
da qua di prendervi un momento per voi e
quindi di
riflettere Pensate se vi è mai capitato
di reputare appunto di aver fallito che
poi fallimenti non
esistono pensate e riflettete se vi è
capitato di vivere un momento in cui
avete visto tutto nero in cui qualcosa è
andato male e poi vi siete impegna
talmente tanto per farlo andare bene e
per raggiungere quella cosa in cui
credevate vi chiedo poi di riflettere
ancora e fare un passettino in più e
chiedetevi con tutto quello che avete
imparato per raggiungere ciò che
volevate che cosa ci avete fatto come
l'avete investito l'avete
investito Ecco quello che voglio dire In
conclusione è siate ambiziosi lottate
per i vostri sogni ponetevi sempre nuovi
obiettivi perché l'ho detto gli
obiettivi sono il motore della vita io
me ne porrò e continuerò a porm
tantissimi non smetterò mai ve lo
prometto insieme a voi però una cosa
riflettiamo sul fatto che tutto quello
che impariamo tutto quello che viviamo
tutte le energie investite il tempo
impiegato può essere utilizzato e può
essere quindi utilizzato per aiutare E
renderlo ancora più forte questo perché
il punto lo definisce e non l'obiettivo
raggiunto